des bosses et rien que des bosses à
jouer les tours les amateurs de skate
roller et trottinette ont trouvé leur
terrain de jeu un peupt track c'est le
nom de ce nouvel équipement vient
d'ouvrir ludique et sensationnel
forcément vous voyez ce reportage de
Sarah gros
ce n'est pas un ciel gris et un peu de
pluie qui ont arrêté Tom cet après-midi
pour aller glisser sur le béton du
nouveau pump track de jouer les tours je
me suis dit que ça allait bien me plaire
donc j'ai acheté un skateboard et puis
je suis venu l'essayer aujourd'hui et
alors et alors c'est super il est
vraiment chouette et c'est assez ludique
c'est vraiment facile et il faut bon
faut prendre un coup de main en roller
trottinette skateboard ou à vélo le but
est d'avancer sur la piste bossu de 180
mètres à l'aide de flexion et l'exercice
semble convenir au grand comme au petit
ça permet aux enfants d'avoir un endroit
un peu sécurisé où il peut faire d'un
vélo trottinette roller ou skate sans
danger d'avoir trop bah des pros ou des
ou des voitures à côté
pour se faire plaisir pas besoin
d'ouvrir son porte-monnaie le premier
pump track de la métropole est
accessible à tous l'important c'est
d'avoir un sport de proximité de ce que
tous les enfants ne vont pas dans des
clubs il faut que l'enfant au sortir de
l'école ils puissent venir faire du
sport dans des plaines de loisirs comme
ici qu'il trouve vraiment de quoi
s'exprimer
112000 euros pour ce nouveau terrain de
jeu un investissement qui s'inscrit dans
la continuité du dispositif sport pour
tous depuis 2020 au fur et à mesure on
puisse en faire un espace un peu plus
complet donc ça veut dire qu'il y a ce
pump track qui est maintenant installé
et ensuite on va aussi rénover et
implanter d'autres outils on a dans
d'autres quartiers de la ville des
espaces fitness des tables de tech ball
des terrains de basket 3.3 pour porter
ses projets la Ville prévoit une
enveloppe d'un million d'euros en 2023